we've really found out so much and so
quickly about our magnificent universe
that's happened really
in the last decades our knowledge has
advanced so much
but there are still tons of fascinating
interesting questions
and what is true is that today's
astronomers and and i
won't get to answer them all um but
happily someone else will
maybe some people in this room thanks
this book is about our quest as humans
to understand
the bigger world that we're part of our
universe
and it's it's about finding out about
our bigger home
we want to know what's out there that
our earth is just a little bit of a part
of
any sufficiently advanced technology is
indistinguishable from magic
a little upbeat music to start this
episode
the into the impossible podcast with a
good friend
and i'm so glad to know that she is my
collaborator
on the simon's observatory a fellow
executive
member of our executive governance board
and that is professor
joe dunkley joining us all the way from
princeton university how are you joe
very well thanks thanks for having me
joe you have been a phenomenal uh
inspiration for many reasons for many
millions of people around the world you
are a professor of physics and
astrophysical sciences at princeton
university
you've won awards from the royal
astronomical society
the institute of physics and the royal
society for her work
on the origins and evolutions of the
universe and we collaborate on the
simon's observatory i couldn't be more
proud
and joe what we normally do is do what
you're never supposed to do
which is to judge a book by its cover
but you know what what other bayesian
priors do we have right joe so um we'll
start off by reading the
uh the the um the title our universe and
astronomers guide
by joe dunkley so joe take us through
the
how you came up with the concept of the
book and what the cover and subtitle
really are supposed to convey
well so this this book actually came up
originally when i was over in the uk i
was working there before i moved over to
the states
um and actually so it it it popped up
um in um as part of the
um pelican guide of books pelican series
of books actually which is supposed to
be
introductions to topics
of interest to kind of the lay public
people who would have
some you know an education but wouldn't
have had a particular education or
training
in these areas of you know that go into
more details about things that
often people think are maybe
overwhelming or too difficult to
comprehend
and so the idea was to you know write
something that
anyone could read and learn more about
you know this beautiful universe around
us and to really keep the level
you know at a pitch that you don't need
you know a degree in physics or really
any equations
either to to pick up some kind of
difficult concepts
and it's very successfully done as such
because it's uh it's not only
informative even for a professional
astronomer
but it's also extremely well written and
delightfully researched and my favorite
are the illustrations because
they're very whimsical but they're very
informative let me get one up here
that has uh one of the classic
illustrations of
space-time bending and a trampoline and
i love the fact that you um don't shy
away from
from going very deep and actually
talking in great depth about some of
these concepts including things like the
acceleration of the universe
the composition of stars and how they're
made and how they're nuclear fusion
reactors
the size scale of the universe you have
unique analogies
um but i guess you worked on with with
somebody credit at the acknowledgements
to somebody at princeton i guess can you
talk more about your collaborator on the
concepts of
some of the illustrations yeah so yes
absolutely i think there's two
so so one thing about the illustrations
i sort of had in my mind the sort of
when when i you know as a professor when
i'm explaining something to
a student or someone who i'm trying to
teach something to
we typically use a chalkboard you know
we we try and simplify diagrams you get
a piece of chalk and you
draw the simplest thing you can to get
across a concept
and so these these diagrams that i
put in the book were kind of inspired by
that concept of like
this is what i would draw on a
chalkboard if i was to be trying to
explain to someone
the you know the the basic idea so
they're not fancy they're not you know
you know you can go to the the web or
other other books of the beautiful
images we have of our cosmos
this was to try and get the concepts in
mind um
yeah but but but then i worked there a
lot of the content
and yeah this the kind of ideas for how
to explain these things
um i picked up from a working with
two you know fantastic women one one was
a a schoolteacher
um eileen levine um who i
taught co-taught a course with
oh gosh about 10 to 15 years ago now
in princeton um where we brought in
teachers from new jersey um
to do a week-long course on astronomy
and cosmology and the idea was that we
were teaching teachers
new you know content they could then
take back to their classroom and teach
their and teach to their classes um
and we got a lot of the content of that
from a nasa educator lindsey bartoloni
who's
who who had who who showed me so many of
the
wonderful materials that nasa had
created for educators to use in the
classroom as well
so we kind of put together this course
based on this these you know this
this this wonderful body of of of work
and then
i learned so much from eileen as a
teacher who was like that's too
complicated we've got to make this
easier you can't say that that's too
difficult
um and we i think got got down to a
level that was that worked
yeah i think it's uh something that um
uh that c.s lewis
coined uh the curse of knowledge which
is that the more
that you know someone becomes erudite
and figuring things out you basically
stop being able to relate to your former
self when
you know he or she didn't know these
advanced concepts gravitational lensing
and origin of the universe but um i
think
the the skill and i think that's
exemplified in in your book
is uh is really indicative of the fact
that you can relate to readers who are
experts you know like me and then but
also
novices at this field um i was curious
about the hour
in the front in what sense is it our
universe or
because it's an astronomer's guide to
our universe are you saying that uh
that the general public can understand
and appreciate the universe as much as
an astronomer or
sometimes i feel it's a reverse we don't
really appreciate what we do and how
privileged we are to be astronomers so
what is the meaning of our in the title
i wanted to you know convey
this this feeling which i believe to be
true which
is that this is our home right that we
are
it's our universe it's it's the place
where we live so as an aside you know we
don't know if there are maybe more
universes out there there's there's
there's this mystery i think where i
should assume that
what we can see is all there is so there
is one kind of there's the kind of
possessive of like i'm just going to try
to describe the bit that we know of you
know that's in one sense our universe
i'm not going to try and you know
speculate too much on what else there
could be but i do think this concept of
like
this is our home it's our we live on
earth
but i want people to feel that this
bigger place
is also something that people can feel
you know
not ownership of but belonging to you
know we belong
to this bigger place and in the same way
that you know we like to learn
we can live in a particular i might live
in princeton new jersey but i
want to know what else is out there in
the world i want to know
um you know what other countries there
are what other people there are
this idea of that we're just taking that
those boundaries a little further
um about learning what other things
there are out there as well
but it's still kind of part of our whole
home and our home our whole story
it's often said that you learn a lot
when you teach
um i find that um and you're a renowned
teacher as well
uh do you feel that you learned even
more by writing the book are there any
things that surprised you in writing the
book or
were you so expert as as as one of the
preeminent cosmologists of of our
of our time did you feel like ah this is
i just want to explain it to people but
do you do
did you actually learn anything new in
the writing of the book the thing i
learned the most was actually the
stories
of some of the scientists um and and
what sort of happened a little bit by
accident
is that i got really um drawn in
by by the personal stories and in
particular
to me i was drawn by a lot of the women
scientists who i
certainly knew of but didn't know so
many of the kind of the
the facets of their lives and and so i
think probably i knew that the science
that i described in the book
i i knew most about science already but
the the way the stories of the people
and the way
the things happened were things that i
then learned more about
in in writing this and that was that was
really fun for me
yeah it's wonderful and of course you uh
received the rosalind franklin award and
the book has a wonderful encomium
uh from dame jocelyn bell bernell
who says this book is simply superb
beautifully written and very clear and
incorporates all the major recent
results and indicates what might come
from telescopes
now being built and i want to thank you
uh
by the way for you know for including
her story or
uh speaking about her so uh so uh
accurately and so and so
um decisively her contributions were to
astronomy uh and it
inspired me last week just as i finished
reading the book for a second time
your book uh to reach out to her and uh
she's gonna be a guest
actually coming on the show and she's
coming on my show on december 10th now
i don't know if you know what december
10th means if you recall
from my book or from other things you
might know do you know whose
date of death that was uh i dare you'll
have to tell me
if you look behind me there's uh there's
some hints so the nobel prizes are given
out
every year on uh december 10th which is
the day i'm going to interview dame
jocelyn bell burnell and one of the
things i'm going to ask her
is about the fact that she was uniformly
regarded as having been snubbed
for the nobel prize won by her phd
advisor and
uh and and another british scientist uh
of course you're you've won the rosalind
franklin award
talk about the status of women and where
you see things is astronomy
uh you know sort of uh exceptionally you
know better worse
how are we doing a lot of our colleagues
on the simon's observatory are women
our spokesperson is uh professor suzanne
staggs
and she is uh you know she's a
phenomenal leader of many projects not
only the simon's observatory
talk about how women have you know come
forth since the time of dame
belle burnell's work uh rosalind
franklin if you want to go back that far
cs woo if you want to go back even
further
talk about you know how you see things
uh
in astronomy uh is there improvement or
do we have a lot long road to go
i think it's a bit of both i think
there's been significant improvement in
the numbers of women
who are in astronomy um and i see them
now
you know emerging at the senior level as
well
um although i will say that at the cnn
it's wonderful to see people take on
leadership of institutions
i see risa wexler in stanford um
now just julian del canton has been
announced as a new director of
uh center for uh competition
astrophysics i keep seeing
uh you know wonderful exciting
announcements of senior women
astronomers taking
uh you know leadership roles um and at
the same time we are seeing more junior
women come through as well so i'm
i'm overall positive and if i look even
around the physics department
where i work overwhelmingly the largest
number of women are in the air at the
subfields
of astronomy um compared to other areas
of physics now that's not to say we i
should we shouldn't be working harder
across physics but i think astronomy is
uh you know is is doing pretty well
but i don't think we're you know we're
not we're not we shouldn't feel too
complacent because i think
there are still challenges and we're
still you know not represented fully
um yeah but i think to me actually what
i'm what i'm also realizing is you know
as a
as a white woman that like there are
there's a there's an issue with lack of
representation of women but there's a
much actually
larger issue of representation across
you know broader
racial and other diversity uh so
you don't uh probably know this but i'm
calling you or speaking i am in the
office formerly occupied by
jeffrey burbidge uh who along with his
uh far more uh accoladed wife
uh um margaret burbidge did some of the
foundational work
of the 20th century in astronomical
observations
and in fact i am uh blessed to have some
of margaret's old plates
that she took before long before you
were born and even a couple months
before i was born
in the uh in the early 1970s and these
are i treasure these and it's in her own
handwriting and i just love these
um but it's impossible not to kind of
you know recognize
that the kind of challenges that she was
uh facing
and and how things might have changed
and she was famous for turning down
certain awards because they were only
offered to women
uh but you're right and i think you know
the challenge i feel
and i was talking about this earlier
this week but um you know
there's there's a twofold challenge in
increasing representation we all want to
do it
uh but we're also you know there's a
sense that
that the past was really bad and and we
do want to make things much better
but it's almost like we're we feel like
we want to make sure that we
do it the right way that we don't burden
our colleagues i have a colleague who's
african-american
neurobiologist here um and uh
you know he's always asked to do stuff
you know he's always asked to be on
committees and serve
and like assuage how different people
are feeling and make them feel better
anyway as a woman does that happen as
well in other words are you put on all
these committees for women and status
and the war
and and is that also sort of like a tax
that women have to pay perhaps that male
astronomers like myself don't
i think so yes i think that i will say i
think that you know senior members
certainly and my colleagues have been
careful to try and protect me from that
but it happens nonetheless because you
may not be asked i think
i'm not probably asked to do that much
formal
um work in that respect because people
are aware of that tax
but it's the informal uh or
or it's it's the informal work of for
example
talking to which i love but talking to
junior junior women and and
and sometimes addressing issues that
have to be brought up you know
informally people might come and talk to
me because
they will see me as someone as a woman
who you know who they might be able to
bring things to
um so i and
i so yeah i do i do definitely feel
there is an extra tax
and some of it is invisible and some of
it's visible and so being aware of both
those parts i think
just people need to keep aware of those
things yeah yeah
yeah i had you know katie mac on a
couple of years ago
long before a book and she was saying
you know it's it's often very
uh trivialized like oh just give a girl
you know pink circuit board
and uh that'll be enough and but also
that she doesn't really want to talk
about it all the time and so
i actually don't want to talk about it
that much more either except to bring up
that margaret left this plate
and of course she was part of the duo
that discovered how uh
the quartet who discovered how nuclear
fusion worked inside of stars to produce
the elements that you and i are made of
and
and meteorites that are the villains of
certain books
but i want to ask you about some of her
more controversial other
associations maybe guilt by association
and that has to do with the origin story
itself of the universe
and they believed along with uh fred
hoyle and renowned cosmologist
that the universe didn't have a singular
origin and yet in this book you make a
very convincing argument
that there was a single kind of big bang
and there's a lot of information
associated with it um is there room for
doubt
i spoke to a fellow uh countrymen and
actually a um
a student of fred hoyle narlikar and he
still has his doubts about the big bang
is there room for doubting the big bang
paradigm
shall we say is there still room for
legitimate not cranks not crackpot but
legitimate criticism of the big bang
so i would say that you know when i talk
about the big bang and there being a
beginning um
i'm talking about the you know
the beginning of the growth of the
universe we see around us today
so i think there's there's huge open
questions about
what that what that point at which we
call the big bang started from where
there was time before there where there
was something before then i think
you know that you've you think about
there's a lot too there's this question
of
of of um could it have come from
something
prior to what we call the big bang was
it something around before
so i i would not i don't think our
current data
tell us about whether what happened or
whether
something around before our expansion
began
but i think that the model we have that
like yes some
some growth has been happening from a
hot big that things were in a hot
dense state you know 14 billion years
ago and have grown since then following
our
um this model of expansion and following
laws of gravity
there's so much data now for that i just
don't i
i don't buy a lot of you know concerns
about
that because we have so much evidence we
have you know we can look at the the
proportions of different elements in the
universe we see this
you know this radiation from from the
big bang just after big bang itself this
cosmic microwave background that we both
study
um and and so much
data now with the beautiful telescopes
we have that i think that story is
while there are big questions in it i
think that story is
is has become robust
yes and i think you know you mentioned
it earlier on in the beginning of the
conversation about
the you know concept that it might not
be the only universe it might just be
our universe and you talk a lot in the
book about
um about uh you know how the universe is
has the appearances as if inflation took
place
this early energetic phase of cosmic uh
cosmic i wouldn't say genesis i think a
lot of people conflate the two
um that inflation doesn't necessarily
have to be the big bang right
joe yeah so what what is most promising
about inflation in your uh as an expert
and then
what are some of the most significant
challenges and things you would like to
see shored up because you actually give
it a very fair treatment
you mentioned our mutual friend paul
steinhardt two-time guest on the into
the impossible podcast
and unlike many other you know guests
that i've had on
you don't assume it's a fate accompli as
our french friends would say so
talk to me about steel man the arguments
against inflation
and then let's dive into what the what
the good parts of inflation are
well so one of the things that is one of
those fascinating questions that
inflation
manages to to address at least i'm not
sure convincingly solved but it's it's
one of these open questions
it wasn't really what first inspired
inflation but you know we see
cosmic structure in the universe we see
galaxies in the sky
like in distributed in this in
a beautiful cosmic web um and the
universe the universe is full of
features
but if we step back to you know the very
early times it was almost feature-less
it was kind of this soup
of particles almost completely you know
uniform density throughout
throughout space but you know
we had to find the that that
almost featureless universe wasn't
completely featureless there were these
tiny lumps
these tiny over dense regions in the
early universe and they were the seeds
of these cosmic structures they were the
things then grow
by gravity over millions and billions of
years to form this beautiful universe
around us now
and one of the huge questions we have is
how why
were the these irregularities in the
early universe in this soup of particles
why were there little regions that were
ever so slightly denser than others
that there would be the seeds of
everything to come later
and inflation which is this you know the
idea that the universe expanded
extremely fast fast in the speed of
light just for very short time
it it it kind of solves that um
in a beautiful way i think and like it's
kind of a this this like
amazing mixture of the quantum mechanics
of the very tiny with the you know
the the general relativity of the very
large that
that that tiny quantum fluctuations in
the very early universe
uh where where particles are kind of
allowed to appear and disappear because
of our uncertainties of
that quantum mechanics tells us we
should be uncertain of um
those combined with a universe that's
growing exponentially fast
kind of freezes in these these these
little
ripples these quantum ripples into huge
macroscopic enormous scales that then
become the seeds of everything else
um and that is a love you know that's
that's good that's beautiful like the
idea that you could that this works
and that this this kind of matching up
of like
tiny quantum fluctuations expanded
enormously and then
they grow then the galaxies that we see
that's very beautiful um trouble is and
that that um
that even though sort of part of the
inflationary models
predicts that indeed you should get
these
these little ripples in the way that we
see them
there are real problems with the theory
as well like it's
it it says that there's also high
chances of getting something looking
completely different
um and so this isn't you know the people
who are saying oh this actually isn't
this model doesn't really work so well
say that that actually there are more
there's you're more likely to get a
universe that looks nothing like the one
we've got
than this particular one which has these
you know elegant little
fluctuations that that match up what we
see
um so there are
that to me like this whatev whatever
whatever was going on has to explain
how we got these this initial you know
initial conditions of the universe it's
got to explain that
um but there are you know other ideas
out there
and when we think about those ideas
sometimes i
have you know friendly arguments with my
friends paul and anna aegis and others
who promote this because eventually
their model in bouncing
cosmology has to incorporate something
like a scalar field
i always tell them i say anna you know
paul
can't you do it without a scalar field
in other words don't replace
the you know the kind of unknown unknown
within inflation
uh which is the scalar field which we
have no evidence of you know currently
i mean there is only one known scalar
field which is the higgs
um still uh how you know how nice would
it be to not have to have this feature
so i
i kind of feel like it even will retain
all these cosmological alternatives and
even sir roger penrose's aeons and
cyclic cosmology
they still retain some kind of scalar
field for which we have no evidence so
i guess the concept the question i have
is how should we evaluate these things i
mean
inflation is stunningly successful but
it cannot account for its own origin
in order to account for its origin it
must invoke the multiverse
um and so does does that trouble you or
is that just really
a signpost that we need better ideas
i think we certainly need better ideas i
think that
um you know what it is remarkable that
there are there are a set of predictions
from inflation that we have sort of
checked off most of them already
we're now uh together right we're look
we're looking for
one of the key predictions of the early
universe of the inflation model of the
universe which is that it should imprint
space-time ripples gravitational waves
permeating the early universe
um and so we we we should we should
certainly look
for them but i think even if we find
them i wouldn't be ready to say
oh inflation happened like this is
exactly this is what it is with
you know problem solved we actually did
do that in 2014 you might remember
well we did but he but even even if that
was not have been right i think you know
we yeah we
that that was a it was it was not even
that was a mistaken result
yeah that even if we had found them and
even when we do i hope we do find them
with simon's observatory or
maybe i should hope we don't because
that might tell us
something into something interesting too
i'm not sure what i hope um
um even then we're still going to have
this gap
where we will say still you know do i
know what inflation is
and why it happened um and so i i i
think that there are still i think there
are issues and i think
um having more
clever minds thinking about those these
theoretical models for the early
universe
i think is really important i feel like
we don't quite have enough right now i
feel like we've got this dominant
paradigm which is inflation we have
these
these these um you know interesting
alternatives
bouncing models but we don't have whole
communities
of other you know theoretical
cosmologists thinking up
other alternatives or subtleties of this
and i i sort of wish we did
yeah so we're gonna nerd out a little
bit now because my audience the into the
impossible audience
is nothing if not the smartest most
brilliant minds in the multiverse
uh your thesis titled the modern methods
for cosmological parameter estimation
beyond the adiabatic paradigm
uh first of all we've had a lot of
people on julian barbour who you
probably know from oxford
uh he was on the show talking about this
entropic
arguments that he has for the origin of
the universe an englishman but he's not
english his name is england jeremy
england we talked about
life and the connection of entropy to
the origin of life and evolution
but i want to ask you first of all what
does adiabatic mean in the context of
cosmological
perturbations and how does that fit into
the inflationary paradigm and then we'll
and then we'll go deep
yeah good so it's a funny word it's a
word that's used in other other
ways in in other parts of physics but in
it's a word that we
we use in cosmology for saying you know
i said i mentioned earlier we we have
these sort of lumps and bumps in the
early universe
and the sort of theory
inflation says that before we had any
particles
we had a scalar field and we don't know
what that is but we're saying we have
the scalar field
and that it was the thing that these
quantum fluctuations
left the irregularities in um
and and so then
we think that that decayed or changed
into the particles we know
so the the baryon the particle normal
baryonic particles that we are made of
rays of light photons neutrinos and we
think also
dark matter particles are also rather
mysterious
if that is that sort of what happened
then all of those
particles all of those different
different ingredients
the particles the light the neutrinos
they should all inherit the same lumps
and bumps
as went into that initial scalar field
so anywhere in the universe there was
kind of an over density of energy in the
scalar field
that will then turn into an over density
of both the particles
and the rays of light and the neutrinos
and the dark matter
all in one place and so the adiabatic
sort of assumption is indeed that that
any over dense region uh in the early
universe
is going to be similarly over dense in
all of the ingredients of the universe
it's not like you'll have one lump of
mata
over here and over here you'll have a
lump of photons
they need to trace each other like if
you imagine drawing i should
go my blackboard is not right behind me
if i imagine drawing a line tracing the
density of the universe with space
the density of the light and the matter
and the dark matter and everything in it
should follow the same pattern
um and and that's again what simple
inflation
would predict because it all came from
this scalar field
um right and when we think about
adiabatic or entropy one of the main
kind of
uh attacks on inflation is that it
it doesn't it makes the problem of the
uh arrow of time
you know particularly uh pernicious
because it's it's really saying the
universe had this extremely low entropy
state in the beginning but it almost has
to be added by hand how does the entropy
behave let's say something happens at
the planck time we don't understand what
inflation happens you know 10 to the
eighth plank times later
10 minus 36 of a second then it lasts
for 10 to the minus
35 i don't know some small amount of
time
and then it emerges uh and it but it has
to emerge in this low entropy state
um wrap my mind my audience's mind
around that how does that
how does that get accomplished so that
it is actually adiabatic
not just thermal equilibrium which you
know you could kind of make sense
although it's hard to really think about
thermalization
of the entire you know what would become
the entire universe effectively but
but nevertheless how does the low
entropy
get asserted if not by fiat which most
cosmologists find anathema
yeah well so i think we're missing we're
certainly missing big pieces of the
story
so we we we usually actually we use you
know usually
um uh when we're tracing through
how these like perturbations evolve we
just give them an
initial condition and we're say i think
what i'm saying is that you know if we
assume
that these fluctuations came from
inflation then we say okay we had some
kind of
we had at the end inflation ended
we decay and produce particles
um but there's still you know big
uncertainties about that
even that process but so i think but
then from sort of when we then
do cosmology onwards right we we say
okay i'm just going to start with some
initial conditions of these ingredients
and i and i'm not going to
exactly worry right now about how i got
from the scalar field
into this initial conditions of those
particles i mean obviously one
plenty of people are working on that but
if we're trying to say what do they what
are the observables in the universe we
tend to just say right what are these
what are the initial conditions of these
different ingredients um we don't we
don't then have to model
that early a bit yeah i agree it's very
interesting to understand
try and figure out yeah exactly i would
say you know if you if you want to study
you know embryology of a chicken or
something you don't actually have to
come up with the how the dna got in the
chickens you know
egg in the first place uh to understand
which came first the chicken or the egg
uh but nevertheless it's interesting and
it's always kind of adjacent it's like i
have uh
i'll have a famous astronomer actually i
had sarah sieger
over the other night for dinner in san
diego and uh she's a world-renowned
astronomer and a guest pass guest on the
into the impossible podcast
and we're just lamenting the fact that
how few astronomers can identify most
constellations i'm not gonna put you to
the test because i know you can
uh but the uh but sarah and i were
joking but i'm all
it's it's not too surprising that we get
asked about these big picture questions
as cosmologists right because we're
we're studying you know the origin of
everything and so people assume we're
gonna be philosophically
inclined to want to know what came first
but maybe more practical question to
answer is
i've never fully been comfortable with
the notion that you know inflation's
this super smoother it makes the
universe exquisitely flat
during the early radiation dominated
phase but um but then after 10 to the
60th
or e to the 60th foldings or whatever it
is um
the best fit model that you and your
colleagues have determined
that it emerges but then it has ripples
and then it has these tiny curvature
fluctuations
um and those are adiabatic as you as you
discussed in your thesis and elsewhere
um how does that work is that another
fine-tuning problem i guess that's my
question for you in in a concise form
does it have to because if they if the
perturbations were present before the
enormous expansion then they too would
get
you know diffused and flattened out um
because they would just amplify outside
the horizon
uh yeah well so the perturbations are
appearing during the expansion so every
so
every time so we well we've got little
quantum fluctuations
that are present um
uh at every scale of the universe's
space as it is at the time and so as we
in
this inflation says i'm exponentially
expanding space so every time i
you know expand double double space
space time
um i'm imprinting these fluctuations
which is why
again we see them we see these this
particular scale and variance we see
fluctuations that look the same whether
we look at like really
really big scales or really small scales
um
so those because they're being imprinted
during the inflation itself if they've
been imprinted if they were there
beforehand you could imagine they might
have been you know washed out
but like they're they're actually coming
in during inflation itself
um due to from the you know from the
physics of the
of the universe growing coupled with
these quantum fluctuations
so you end up so that then they get thro
you know it's essentially frozen in on
big you know on
visible macroscopic scales during it um
and but it is this lovely thing that
like that makes it quite a specific
prediction that because inflation had to
end and it slowed down
you actually even though you get almost
as the kind of same size
features at very large angular scales
are small
you actually get like slightly um
um slightly smaller features at the
smaller scales
um and that's the departure just for the
list that's the departure of ns from
unity
yeah that's exactly and what i mean it's
been it's been really exciting because
it's only been since the flank satellite
that you know we saw this
for the first time high significance
that actually that's indeed what we see
is this departure from from scale and
variance and so yeah i guess
we are we are actually seeing the kind
of
if indeed that comes from inflation
again it might not
right we're seeing that kind of the the
evolution of like how
the expansion went during that during
those e-folds
and how what else you you put in a
little caveat there with uh
appropriate candor but what other models
would predict a departure
that could be seven sigma or five
whatever you guys have measured it to
significant departure from ns from one
um what you know i mean in other words
what uh what other alternative models or
is it just other models of inflation
that could predict it and invade that
test yeah
my my impression is that even though
it's very nice
so it is it is pretty compelling to me
that that i think was one of the most
important results of the planck
satellite was this
was this measurement um and it has made
non-inflation builders life i think more
challenging
because of this because it is rather
specific um and so i i feel sure that
there can be other ways of doing it i
would say either there are two things
either there's a different way of doing
it or we there's still a possibility
that
that we've got it that it's not less
than one
because if you want to throw in some
other strange physics
you know we get these numbers from the
universe by looking at our observations
very carefully but we make assumptions
and so in
in detecting this ns less than one this
slight scale invariance
we've assumed everything else about the
model of the universe we've assumed that
it's what we call lambda cdm it's this
flat universe it's got only
three ingredients etc we might have got
some of that a bit wrong still
even though we don't think so even
though we you know we've done our best
so far to say
you know given all we know this is our
best bond model
there might still be some new physics in
there some some new some chimney model
behavior
that actually could give some
diff slightly different some infer some
different scale dependence even from the
data we have in hand
and sometimes people say things like you
know inflation's prediction of the flat
universe
is not really a prediction it shouldn't
count as a prediction
um or or even uh you know or it's not
even a problem
in some sense um what do you make of
that the classical pillars
on which inflation's credulity rests are
they observe flatness absence of spatial
curvature the observed um
you know uh the isotropy of the
microwave background but not perfectly
isotropic
and then and then the absence of
magnetic monopoles which is a
non-observation so
i i agree we really and that was goof's
original motivation
as i'm under led to understand what do
you make of the flatness
should we stop using it as a
justification that inflation is well
motivated
i think i think the flat the fact that
our universe is
does appear to be almost perfectly or
exactly geometrically flat which means
you know
light travels in parallel lines but it's
that
it's not uh that it probably stretches
out and stretches out it's a good you
know not like the surface of an orange
but like it serves a piece of paper
um that is a surprising
um measurement if we made no assumptions
about the early universe because
i remember you know this is one of the
things i remember doing as an under you
know undergraduate
um is you can derive that you know you
can
show that if you just have some
departure from perfect flatness of the
universe and you just let it evolve
it will get much more much less flat and
that's this big that was this big
problem it's like
this incredible fine tuning you need at
the very beginning of the universe
that the universe starts off incredibly
close to flat if it's going to look
pretty flat today and so that is
no any any viable model has got to
address that
um and so that was one of the reasons
one of the things that inspired
inflation but
so so yeah and anything that's not that
better better address that issue
right and then uh the final thing that i
hear a lot about and i'd love to get
your
uh professional professorial opinion
reminder we're talking with professor
joe dunkley princeton university
renowned cosmologist friend and
collaborator on the simon's observatory
such a pleasure to talk to our friends
and
this interview has been two years in the
making since our universe came out and
i've been dying to get you on the show
and something happened in the world of
health related matters that we're not
going to talk about that delayed many
uh times our interviews with our kids
and our schedules
but we're talking about right now some
of the nitty gritty nerding out on
inflation
so one thing i'm often let her led to
believe from inflation is that it
predicts something about quantum gravity
in other words an observation of
primordial b-mode perturbations
would in some sense validate the notion
that gravity was quantized
during the inflationary epoch what do
you make of those kinds of
claims and in what sense is is a b mode
a classical b
mode gravitational wave and and gr is a
classical theory as you know better than
anybody
um in what sense is the observation of a
classical gravitational wave
any bearing on whether or not gravity is
quantized
well i think it depends on your model so
when what we're all looking you know
we're busy looking for this this imprint
of gravitational waves
um on the cosmic microwave backgrounds
and but the physics of that doesn't uh
you know is not
necessarily assuming that gravity is
quantized you know we've seen the
gravity that those beautiful
gravitational waves already from in
spiraling black holes from ligo
and it's again it's just a prediction of
relativity
um and so if we find that imprint
from the early universe i don't think we
instantly saying uh anything more than
we have found that signal you know we've
seen we we can first of all say
you know yes we've seen gravitational
waves um
produced from some mechanism in the
early universe
i don't think we can then say with
certainty it therefore
must have come through this you know
this this this
mechanism where i've come i've you know
quantized gravity have come from quantum
fluctuations etc
um but but it's certainly but it's one
of the parts i think if we of course if
we see them if we detect them
then you know people will be busy
exploring these options and trying to
determine how
with what certainty we could say that's
is what happened
but i think that we won't be able to say
that with
um i expect within you know there will
still be options i suspect for
you know other possible um
mechanisms and when we look at the
inflationary paradigm you know one
complaint i hear about it is that you
know
it's kind of like string theory it takes
up all the you know best and brightest
young minds and
and there are too few people working on
alternatives to inflation
um do you think that's a problem do you
think there should be you know i had
michio kaku
on who is you know is the father of
string
field theory along with other people and
i asked him well you know how much
should we spend on alternatives to uh to
string theory and he said well 50 50.
you know and i thought that's you know
if i made you
um uh director of the nsf which maybe
someday you will be but uh but
if i made you uh you know in charge of
funding and so forth
would you how would you allocate balance
the portfolio of research that's done by
theorists or your theoretical colleagues
well and one thing i would say is i
think there were so many you know
the the origin of the universe is a huge
question there are other huge questions
too even in cosmology you know the
the the may not be connected about the
um
you know the invisible universe the dark
universe um but within the early
within the early universe modeling um i
think it's really important to support
the alternative models uh modeling or
thinking
thinking of alternatives um and you know
but in that respect i'm biased i always
want to
have the have a strong focus on now
let's figure out what to measure
um and connect those those those
theories to what are we best what should
we best go and measure to really give
as many possibilities to the theorists
and
one example that you know we're doing
with the simon's observatory is
we're not only looking for gravitational
waves
that are kind of one of the things that
people are looking for for inflation but
we're also going to measure these like
tiny flux
the tiny ripples in space-time that
produce galaxies
at really fine scales to try and get a
broader lever arm on what they look like
because as i said
said before you know the planck
satellite has said yeah these these
fluctuations look almost scale invariant
and they follow
this pattern but we must go and look for
anything else that could be telling us
something new
so i think perhaps what i'm saying is
that that observations if i was fun you
know
funding projects you want to fund i
think
things that give you the most
information possible not perhaps about
just one facet but like about
you know many different views of a
problem and then yeah ideally
supporting a variety of theory
theorists so at the end of the book uh
you conclude with a beautiful passage
you say the most exciting discoveries
are the ones we least expect
ones that can radically change what we
thought was true and ultimately lead us
to a better understanding of our wider
world
we look forward to them with eager
anticipation i always think it's it's
kind of funny when i say like oh we have
to look for serendipity
because by definition you're not going
to do it but what do you say to people
that
you know say look you know simon's
observatory or some other experiment
you know we're basically not going to be
able to say that inflation definitely
took place as you just said
if we detect b modes because something
else could purport it or we're not going
to be able to rule out inflation either
right because
inflation could have occurred but at too
low an energy regime to create
observable uh primordial perturbations
other goals involve
you know looking for evolution of dark
energy well it doesn't seem to really
have any hints that it's really
quintessence or evolving dark energy and
then looking for neutrino masses
and well we have a good lower bound and
we have a good upper bound we just don't
know the exact result so why is it
important to do
these measurements with precision why is
that important
and is serendipity as much as we love it
is that is that a good justification
for doing scientific research i think
ideally you want to be able to have an
experiment that can do both
i think you you of course you need to
build something where there is something
that you're
you you're after and neutrinos are an
interesting example
actually because we know that neutrinos
exist and we know that they have mass
and we don't know what they are
what that mass is we don't actually know
if they behave cosmologically like we
think they do
so there actually is huge scope for
discovery there i think this whole
sector of particles that we
that we really don't fully understand so
to me that's an interesting area where
you know you say yes i'm going to build
an experiment that can go and measure
the neutrino mass assuming they behave
in the universe like they seem to do
here on earth or in the local
local universe but then i think you want
to build try and build your experiments
in a way that say
um that give you the most opportunity to
find
uh you know stranger behavior that you
didn't that you weren't sure of um
so i do think that the ideal experiments
we're seeing that with large
cosmological surveys actually that you
build them to target a few key questions
and then you collect a huge amount of
data
and realize you know that you could
actually look for things in different
ways and hopefully find something new so
um i think my favorite my favorite
experiments
have a bit of both you know and
obviously they're probably not going to
get supported unless they have a bit of
the first one which is something that
you actually think
is worth going to measure okay so for
the last
nerding uh adjacent question i want to
talk about
ineffective this is probably the least
known but
maybe the most interesting parameter
that simon's observatory and other
projects can go after
what is ineffective why do we expect
there to be a departure from
the standard model and maybe you can
talk about what the standard model
predicts for an effective
and um you know what do you think our
prospects are
yeah so so what this number ineffective
it characterizes the
mostly characterizes the number to begin
with just the number of
types of neutrino particles in the
universe
of which we are pretty sure there are
three that's what we've measured
um you know lab-based and and local
measurements
um but that number in a broader sense
cosmologically
measures how many actually just in
general
relativistic particles there are um or
species of particles where relativistic
particles something that
certainly in the early universe was
traveling you know almost the speed of
light
and again we think that it's just three
neutrinos
but there may be more particles out
there
um and many models for the early
universe would say actually yeah there
should be there should have been
additional kind of particles created in
the early universe that would also be
left behind
streaming through our universe now and
the subtlety is if they were produced
um or if they sort of stopped
interacting with other particles
much earlier on than the neutrinos did
then they would
then they would sort of look in our data
as if they were some fraction of a
number so we talk about this number like
the number of particles of the effective
number of particles
but an extra kind of species of like a
novel new relic particle might only
contribute like
a tenth of a of a of a number of
particles
so it might be that we go out and we
measure not three
but 3.1 as this number and 3.1 would be
really exciting because it would say
that there was actually some additional
you know density stuff in the universe
made of
rapidly traveling particles that are not
in our current standard model of physics
um so uh sadly we will
purpose on sadly but maybe a bit sadly
we've already ruled out the fact that
there's a whole other neutrino species
you know we went down through a few
years ago with our new data we said okay
four
is ruled out with our data so anything
that is in there has got to be just some
fraction of a number
which again corresponds to particles
that stopped interacting at a much
higher temperature in the universe than
neutrinos
but they might be there and and and so
we're looking for that that that slight
departure from
three again you do expect some official
departure from three just because of the
just because of like tracking the heat
of the early universe but
nonetheless three neutrinos should give
a very specific number and any
any addition to that will be new physics
new particles
and this will be different from uh say
the potential dark matter candidate
called the axion correct
so do you want to explain uh what is an
axion why do cosmologists get so excited
about it
and how can we maybe measure it with
experiments like the simon's observatory
well accidents are very interesting so
so
if they're one of the candidates for
dark matter so we have
um a huge amount of mass in the universe
that's invisible to us
about five times as much mass as the
matter that we're made of
is is dark matter and until quite
recently i think many people
assumed that this dark matter was made
of
um what we call wimps weakly interactive
massive particles
something you know heavier than the
electrons i think things that we're made
of
um but now that there's a renewed
interest i think
or there always was but there's i think
it's probably an increase lately
for axions very very light particles to
be the source of dark matter instead
um and they'd be incredibly incredibly
light but
you know but the total energy of energy
density of them would be enough to
account for this invisible
matter um they they're actually sort of
different flavors of them some of them
could be the dark matter
of the cold this this cold dark matter
they could also be
um uh contribute a smaller amount of the
energy in the universe
and and just be very and contribute
to this number that we're looking for
that's ineffective it does depend
on the kind of the kind of axiom but
it's it's um
yeah we'll we'll just have to see yeah
it'll be exciting
okay joe we've come to the end but i
want to ask you one of my big picture
questions and actually relates to
the late great former countrymen of
yours uh sir arthur c clarke who said
many things including
uh for every expert there is an equal
and opposite expert
he said uh any sufficiently advanced
technology is indistinguishable from
magic
and he also said the only way to
discover the limits of the possible
is to venture beyond them into the
impossible and that's how i got the name
of this podcast because
i am the co-director of the arthur c
clark center for human imagination at uc
san diego
i want to ask you joe what mysterious
aspect of life
seemed impossible to a 20 year old joe
dunkley
but now makes sense and gave you the
courage give yourself the courage
and gave you the courage perhaps to go
into the impossible
well i i i guess i'll answer that in a
in a slightly
perhaps not the same way as uh
as envisaged of a knowledge thing but i
to me
it's the thing of doing something that
you didn't think you were capable of
right so my 20 30 year old self
wouldn't have thought that i could for
example write a book right this seemed
impossible
um something that seemed something that
only you know someone else does right
not me
um and so i think that the thing that
i've probably learned
in the past in this last 10 years or so
is that you can do those things you can
do things that's actually seem
impossible to do i had this sort of
dream like i'd love to write like i'd
love to write a book i'd love to
be able to do this um and it seemed
impossible
and so then it was some advice and
support i was like oh maybe i can do
this
and now you know it seems like that's
that's something achievable so i
to me that's a it's not a scientific
knowledge thing that that's
learning but it's a kind of a what your
yourself is capable of
yeah that's beautiful in fact it reminds
me of what audrey hepburn said
the word impossible tells you that
nothing's impossible because the word
says i'm
possible so a little advice from audrey
hepburn great scientist as i'm sure she
was
but joe dunkley i'm so pleased to be
able to talk with you today
and to benefit from the wisdom and
knowledge in your wonderful book our
universe available everywhere books
are consumed and i just want to add
further gratitude for being a member of
our collaboration
and the leader of it and i look forward
to seeing you next week is our face to
face or
screen to screen meeting and i can't
wait to hear from you uh next week along
with all the great stuff you do at
princeton university joe dunkley thank
you so much for going into the
impossible
thanks brian any sufficiently advanced
technology
is indistinguishable from magic
[Music]
you